and you of course when you came and
talking about your book brave talked
about being a former member of a cult
you actually think there are some
parallels between the United States and
the cult oh I know there are I was
introduced to America at a boarding
school and military school and I was 10
and what I surmised were very early ages
people telling me how strange it was how
I grew up and to that I countered I find
it very strange how you live which to me
means you're living in a class structure
and an oppressive system that operates
exactly like a cult specifically with
America we're number one don't leave
here it's scary out there the news that
is so controlled and showing there that
never shows anything around the world
other than migrants for people trying to
break into the United States take what
we have you know it does a huge to
service the American public but it also
does a huge disservice the world and
this cult-like way of thinking really
needs to be smashed so what's going on
right there in America right now I'm
incredibly proud of them
[Music]
you